if you're someone that believes you waste a lot of time or maybe you're just not
productive enough maybe you don't get enough done maybe you're overthinking procrastinating or don't know how
to make a plan this video is for you because I'm going to show you the
eight ways that I save more time make more time and create more with my time
let me ask you a question how many of you believe that you're good at multi-tasking
now studies show that only two percent of the world's population is actually able to multitask
and researchers say that when people here that they always assume that there in that two
percent maybe you're sitting there at home thinking the same thing the truth is most of
us are in the ninety-eight percent save researchers and therefore we have to focus on something
called single tasking or monit asking this is the idea that we focus on one thing
at a time this sounds counter-intuitive a lot of people say well if I'm doing less
things that's going to take more time the truth is when you focus on one thing
at one time not only does your productivity and your efficiency go up your fatigue goes
down and your stress goes down as well next time you get lost in that battle
of trying to do loads of different things at the same time press pause take a
step back take a breath and just focus on that one activity this applies to eating
it applies to driving it applies to texting it applies to speaking on the phone or
a zoom call just do that one thing a few years ago I read a study
that changed the way I live you can't be logical and creative at the same time
your brain and mind is using different faculties and different abilities to do different types of
tasks imagine your own meetings all day about numbers and data and analytics and all of
a sudden you're asked to do something creative maybe you write a speech or give a
presentation it can be really really difficult to switch from one side of your brain to
the other side in a matter of seconds with very little organizing and planning were literally
going like a pendulum swinging from one task to another which is requiring different parts of
our brain and the abilities that we have the way I solve this is that I
start every day by first writing down might to do list I look at all the
activities that I have to do now in the examples are given this video I've simplified
my task to make it easier but no could I do this with a lot more
detail you want to draw a line down the middle of the page on one side
of it right logical and on the other side of it right creative you now want
to plot and mark where these tasks on your to-do list to fit either in the
logical category or in the creative category the question you're asking yourself is is this task
largely structured focused does it have certain boundaries is it quite a logical step by step
process or is this creative is it more of a brainstorm is it somewhere where you
need to feel free and express it after you've divided these tasks you now want to
write down the time estimate that that specific task is going to take what ends up
happening is you start to plot your week by saying Monday is going to be created
chooses a logical Wednesday's a logical those days are creative and Fridays our creative or you
may also divide your day into logical mornings and creative afternoons or creative mornings and logical
afternoons this division this time blocking allows you to get really immersed into the activity really
focus and be more productive and effective so this might be unpopular opinion but I live
by this and it has truly been a game changer in my world if it's not
in the calendar it won't get done it's not really a priority right you have to
make sure that it's in your plan it's in your day so I'm gonna show you
quickly what my calendar and schedule look like that is my life this month as you
can see its color coded its beautifully designed and as I flick through this what you
realize is that every single day I have everything from workout time to meal times to
scheduled off time all in my calendar what this allows me to do is it helps
me prioritize both personal and professional commitments and helps me see both things in the same
place if you haven't put something in your calendar even if it's something social I promise
you you'll need to forget it or you won't plan effectively around it when I know
I have a really big podcast or a really big interview but if I know that
I have a big deadline on a day I don't then surround that day with other
difficult and challenging tasks sometimes I'll start my day with the most challenging task of the
day because I feel that I need to start with the challenge and sometimes I actually
put it as the last most challenging task of the day because actually I want to
build that momentum when you have a schedule you get context around how you feel that
were you manage your mental health and well-being a million times better and you do more
with less time
tell me how many times you've experienced this you check everything off your to-do list but
you still feel unfulfilled you've used your time wisely you've managed to accomplish every task but
you still end the day when your head hits the pillow you still feel like you
failed you still feel like you didn't quite achieve something I realized that this happened to
a lot of top performer and it was because they weren't asking themselves what do I
need to do today that will make me feel like today has been a good day
you don't think that today is a good day because you did everything you wanted to
do you have to feel like it's been a good day so I do this activity
every single day where I ask myself the question what do I need to do today
that will make me feel like today has been a success for you it may be
reading your children a bedtime story it may be making sure that you made ten minutes
to meditate it may be that you have got to work out in or you had
your green juice it has to be something simple that's easily repeatable on a daily basis
but that you prioritize doing it writing down what you did every day gives you ideas
for the future as well and plotting it out in this way it makes it really
really simple to remember what you could try on another day how many of you feel
like the months or just passing by and it's crazy to believe that were over a
quarter of the way through the year but this is what happens when we don't have
really clear goals targets and tasks this approach has really helped me manage my time better
I have big monthly goals I have for weekly targets and I have one daily task
the one daily task is the baby step towards the weekly target and the weekly target
added up or four of them leads to the big monthly goal so what you're doing
here in essence is breaking down something that feels quite unachievable impossible to do and quite
challenging into small manageable chunks sometimes you can be sitting there thinking wow I don't know
how I'm gonna get that done by the end of this month if you've ever felt
that way use this model first come up with how can you break that big girl
down into four separate tasks once you have these four weekly targets now only need to
do is divide each weekly target into a daily task so basically you end up working
on something daily that you achieve weekly which helps you achieve something monthly now you've completely
deconstructed this impossible unachievable idea into something very simple and manageable now I know I said
to you earlier that you should focus on single tasking not multi-tasking but here's a way
that you can actually get more out of the same time I learned this from a
good friend Arianna Huffington who speaks about habit stacking now we all have habits in our
life that we do every single day without even thinking about it we're driving around town
where cooking every single day we may be on a walk these are great times to
immerse in those activities for sure when you're driving to be fully present if you're going
on a hype to be really there with in nature and if you're cooking to be
really present with the sense the sounds and and all of the different colors that may
be
but if you're someone who can do some of those things pretty comfortably you can also
add a stack of a habit so for example you may be someone who listens to
an audio book while driving you may be someone that listens to a podcast while cooking
or while you're on a hike or walking the dog it's okay to have it stack
in those scenarios to get more out of the same amount of time I've heard about
this in my book it's called location has energy time has memory when you do something
in the same place every day at the same time every day that space birds and
energy and that time Bode's in memory what does that mean when you've done something in
one place like meditated in the same place for a considerable amount of time that space
takes on a meditative energy and frequency it becomes easier to do that activity in that
place and similarly when you do something at the same time every day that time has
a memory your body your mind remember that and therefore it becomes easier to do divide
your home even in corners I remember when my wife and I lived in a five
hundred square for the partner and literally every corner of that room was divided into a
meditation corner a social corner a work corner and an eating corner even that differentiation allowed
you to keep the energy of that space sacred and appropriate for what you want to
do the challenge today is we eat what we're meant to sleep we sleep where were
meant to work and we work where were meant to eat so we've confused the energy
of our environment that's why we're sitting in bed and can't sleep because we do so
many different activities then remove that energy from the bedroom place it where it needs to
be and allow yourself to see how you use your time more effectively in that place
a lot of people think sleep is a waste of time I don't getting good quality
sleep is integral to making more out of the time you have when you're awake I
consistently sleep for eight hours a night and I'm really really happy about it because I
know that it allows me to perform better mentally and physically throughout the day one of
the things I will add though is that you want to be sleeping before midnight the
sleep before midnight is extremely powerful and is really critical for the hts the human growth
hormone to be activated so if you're sleeping a nine pn and you're getting those three
hours before midnight that's extremely powerful or even to if you're sleeping at ten PSO getting
seven to nine hours of sleep and it is critical to being productive with your time
when you are awake don't fall into that trap of that habit to believe that you
should be sleeping less to do more with your time a lot of the tips of
shared today are things that I learned from an incredible book by Daniel Levitan called the
organized mind I recently dive back into it using the blankest app to look at the
blinks that they had around the critical lessons that you can learn from this phenomenal book
you can also listen to these blinks as well that makes it really easy to digest
and remember I love that everything I loved about this book was captured in the blinks
and that it made it really easy to synthesize how I could turn these lessons into
a practical steps right now blankest has a special offer just for our audience go to
blankest dot com forward slash J shd to start your free seven day trial and get
twenty five percent of a blankest premium membership that's blankest spelled bell and Katie dot com
forward slash J shd to get a twenty five percent off and a seven day free
trial thank you so much for watching this video I hope that you're going to practice
just one of these steps to make more out of the time that you have I
wish you all the best and I'll see you soon